Hello, welcome to
the last session of today's science and technology symposium in Korea, Genotoxic Impurities in Pharmaceutical Market, Update and
Analysis Solution.
Sensing Linda
will be there for 10 hours.
Please feel free to enter the kns chat window there.
In this session, I will tell you about the update status of regulation for toxic impurities in the 4th single pt well, which has been an issue in the pharmaceutical market since last year
. Nitro 3, one of the most important genotoxic impurities
next  In nd, various analysis methods are being introduced for the menu.
Next, I will talk about the related content. Then, I will talk about
what impurities mean in the pharmaceutical market, how they can occur, and how they
must be managed.  I'll give it to you. As you
all know, I'm talking about raw materials with impurities in the pharmaceutical market, and chemicals that you don't want out of the complete stir.
Infinity can be divided into three types.
Oh, it can be generated during the student process of the raw material drug or the production of the finished product.
Also, secondly, because of the inherent instability of the apa stain in the drug,
it can be the result of the activity of the impurity.
Second, additives may be added during the development process of complete works
. Due to these additives, impurities may be generated depending on the mutual interaction of a pool.
There is also such an infinite that can occur due to api interaction in the intestine.
This term is expressed as extractor bleaching fire.
Then why should it be managed?
Because
of this, it is possible to determine the quality and efficacy of medicines.
Because of this, of course, because of the stability problem,
impurities in medicines must be finalized.
Therefore, confirmation, qualitative quantification, and management of impurities are
the most  You can see it as a strange part.
Then
, I will tell you about the regulations for each
infinity in the
infinity analysis process.
In the
case of organic compounds 6 part 2 part 22, there is a guideline for raw materials for rc jji q3 gay
q repair damage is set as a guideline for finished medicines
You can see that in the case of solvent impurities, q3 of ic lg is included,
and then in the case of metal laughter, rc gq 3t is included
.
I'll give you something that could have been strong, so
r c gm7 handles it separately.
Then we'll look at what level these management regulations are
.
If the maximum dose is 2 g, then
among the drugs for cargo, the
reporting level is 0.05 bar cents, then the structure confirmation level is 0.10
bar cents, and then the part that needs to be confirmed toxicity is managed for compounds for more than 0.15%
have to
1 As I said before, genotoxic impurities should be managed much lower than normal phosphorus philips
, so if you follow the toxicology grade threshold ptc basis mentioned in Toxicology Sprout, you have to take
1.5 micro g of
this egg per day, but the toxicological basis that it is safe  Because there is this
example, to check, in the case of taking 1 gran per day,
the control standard for toxic impurities before Toxic Infinity 1 is
1.5 ppm.
Then, let's take a brief look at what these genotoxic impurities mean.
Genotoxicity is
the permanent transfer of the amount or structure of genetic material in a person's body or organ.  It is expressed as such impurities that change the possibility.
To explain more easily, we express such substances that can change the dna that contains dna genetic information in the human body as
a number of genotoxic weapons
. What causes these genetic changes  It's called a mitosis mutation. The
agents that cause these changes are not expressed as utogen mutagens
.
4 Toxin Purity South Utah Genie City If
you damage or mutate a certain dna, you can eventually
see the scene yesterday that can cause cancer.
In conclusion, cases like genotoxic 20 can cause final cancer
Then
, the word classification for the genotoxic impurities related to rc Chien Seven has been classified from Hulu 1 Class One to Class 5.
Let's take a quick look at
this first.  In this case
, it means a substance that has been confirmed to be
carcinogenic and mutagenic. As a result of toxicity tests that have undergone such a substance with clearly confirmed carcinogenicity and paralysis, it is necessary
to set the substance * management standard separately and achieve an erection
.
However, in the case of substances with confirmed mutagenicity, they must be
managed through the aforementioned toxicity point threshold pc-based.
For the
general alarm structure that can indicate , it can be classified into three classes.
When classifying these three classes, the younger ttc base is
used
, or through the experiment under the bacteria test, whether or not the child is toxic or not.  First
of all, if a
negative reaction is made that there is no genotoxicity in this case after discrimination, you can go down to Class 5
and manage it as a general impurity.
If it seems to be the
same case, if the same class is mutagenic, there is a structure, but
through the same structure experiment as the main component synthesis intermediate, etc., neutral synthesis
intermediates have been confirmed that there is no parallel order. In the case of the same case, according to the general organic compound
guidelines, ic gt repair technology  Depending on the b,
it seems that you can manage it like a general Infinite. In
the case of Grass 5l, various barrack warning structures cannot be indicated, and
then even if there is sufficient data to prove mutagenicity or
inconsequentiality, as in the class, this  Depending on the repair cost,
I think you can manage it like a normal Infiniti
. I told you about the classification of
genotoxicity for rc gm 3 water from class one to class five.  Let me tell you about structure.
There are structures in various cases. Uh warning structures are
high structural or reactive groups of molecules that are related to the carcinogenic and dreaded disease properties of a
chemical. These are mutagenic and carcinogenic chemicals.  It
can be said that it is a kind of coordination of a series of hearing studies to highlight the mechanism of action
of , and the identification of the case structure
can be seen as showing great value both in terms of understanding the mechanism and risk assessment by chemicals.
In conclusion, as shown on the left  Existing structures can be expressed as a warning structure.
If there is a cloud to do this structure function for such a drug in the pharmaceutical market, I
think you can refer to it as a structure if it can cause genotoxicity.
You can see that it is all there
.
Then I will briefly tell you about the contents revised in March last year in relation to genotoxic impurities in Korean regulations.
First of all, the stability of drug genotoxicity or wind impurities and metal bruce water
Article 7 has been amended for submitting supporting data, and
you can see that this content was revised on March 29 of last year.
First of all, if you look at the contents first,
reagent starting material intermediates used in the manufacturing process  As data proving the stability of probable substances and decomposition products,
it was expressed as submitting the following data.
As you all know, this genotoxicity 2 is determined through a program called qs ar injection,
or if there is a return, there
is an as test for this experiment.
Results 1 to 1 on the wind in the case of genotoxic or carcinogenic hazards.
I think you can see it as the content of the regulation that says that all the same data must be submitted as data proving that it is managed
below
the level of 00,000 examples. Then, secondly, the same is true for finished drugs.
As data proving the stability of decomposition products that can be generated during stability thumb tests such as tests, submit the following data,
so in the same way as in principle 5, the
toxicity prediction program q4 is only a program called genotoxicity through the reverse mutation time variation test.
In the same way, if genotoxicity 2 is determined, submitting data to admit
that it is managed at a level of less than 1/100,000 on the wind
is a revision of the original drug or finished pain.
Also, the book is related to the content  In November of last year, the Food and Drug Administration and the Ministry of Health and Welfare jointly
announced measures related to grapes
.
Regarding Dillo medicines, out of the drug substances, 13 out of 93 drugs completely
exceeded the management standard in charge, so the sales of related items were suspended
.
So at that time, there was no evaluation of the possibility of occurrence until May of this year, and the
test inspection was conducted by the deadline in May 2011, and
instructions were given to try and report.
The report on the evaluation has
already passed and the required test is due until May next year, so there is not much time left,
but if you tell me about the latest update, it can be said that the domestic mdma occurrence
possibility evaluation game
has been postponed, and impurities such as the 2nd m&a Possibility Boobs
Rating 5 in 2020  It was extended until December 30, 2026, this
year, and it was confirmed that the submission deadline for the test inspection result report was extended to the end of next year
.
You are familiar with everything, but
it would be nice if you could confirm once again that the related content has been postponed and the evaluation of the possibility of occurrence has become mt
.
First of all, it became an ng m&a issue in the 4th episode in July
2018. So, the related city constitution was related to Juju Single Mass, so
the analysis method that analyzed n dma was a must.
Second, in October 2010,
the lcms scalpel method capable of detecting up to nd m&e was disclosed for sartanyo raw material finished medicines for 6 living species in pando.
Regarding drug finished products, the related municipal constitution was released in 2019 city circle,
and then this jockey was also released in
November.
How much is contained
in muddy water? The quantitative test method became air
. The latest test is all about it. In January 2020, a method for detecting
n dma for raw material control drugs for mat forming, a diabetes treatment,
was released
. Protected by the bath scalpel method.  This is an opportunity. A
total of 2 analysis methods related to the gc
cms miss foot method and a total of 4 pumice methods related to
the open response have been aired as you all know
.  I will tell you about the global situation.
First of all, mdma, which was the most problematic  In the same case
, it started with the origin of the 4th shot
. In May 2018, in the case of using 2y
Chinese Huai raw materials in European ema, there is a possibility of occurrence of n dm.
18, which was the first issue, also
became an issue in May.
Also, in July of the same year, fd said that the 2nd m&a could occur in the finished product of Wan 8 Satan,
so it
became a problem, so 2018 also became a problem in July.
Then the ending  In this case, in October 2018, it became clear
that mdma and d e could occur in the 1-eup doctor who took all 4 rides from the fda
. In addition, in February 2019, problems also occurred for Anne mba
Also, 100 Finally, in April of 2010, it became an issue that
a pardon with nitro may occur for en eip and ipad 2 2 2 types in fd,
so nd m&n mb
anime ip and ip This is about a total of 5 types  It's been a big issue, and
fda ema has caused various problems in Europe and the United States.
So, domestically, this related city constitution is open to the public, so it can be regarded as absolute.
I can tell you about the status of the analysis method using the lc scalpel or the ac hyrule, mainly through the math scalpel
. You can see that the committee's Razel Unt equipment or third-party equipment has become a lot of air.
To find related test data
I think you can check the data by entering the reference internet address bar on the right.
So far, I have told you about the current status of regulations on cargo of genetic books
.  I'll explain.
As I said before, you  I said that in the case of toxic compounds, general leaves
should be managed at much lower concentrations than
Rote.  In some cases, it
can be analyzed with an hp cuv detector or a rat cfi detector,
but in the case of much lower concentrations such as genotoxic compounds, 1ppm percent
a is usually identified, 0.0001% in water
.
Analysis must be performed through an analyzer.
Next, I will introduce what equipment should be damaged and used to analyze genotoxic impurities.
First, for example, in the future,
barstatin  First, you need to conduct the first monitoring for the level of management regulation using hplc, which Infinity has a
certain percentage or
more.
First, it is confirmed whether it is 0%, and
then, secondly, the molecular formula for the foreign substance can be confirmed by screening the impurity that needs to be confirmed in the 0.1 0% structure
through an equipment called hrs q top.
Through this data  Thirdly,
with the data from this q tower,
you can check the molecular child or 9 stocks through software.
Lastly, if foreign substances are confirmed through this verification work,
you may have to obtain a standard product at the end.  Since
it is necessary to obtain a standard product by traction through a mass mass spectrometer rather than based on
curd, it is possible to divide the analysis into 9 parts in four steps.
Let me
give you a practical example.  24 hours at 40 degrees  If you do a d gradient in the house test during the period,
if the
foreign substances are the same, you can use the top high resolution number
to profile Infiniti as follows, and you can check all the contents of this structure.
First, through the house test like this  When certain substances increase to a certain level or higher
concentration, they can be analyzed through the hms q top.
Second, as I said before, the molecular formula poison through the software
is the actual user who knows what substance is made in what form through the structural formula.  You can analyze while confirming.
Also, the third is, as I said before, for those materials that have actually been tested at home
, with a compound with increased pt
, a black sean corrector is installed through a mass-based rather than uv-based
separation  You can even see how to obtain a standard wind by doing. In the
agent,
solutions that can be analyzed in various ways with various equipment
are presented
.  I am also working on a cow that can analyze light for these.
The main thing to say here is, as I said before,
if you can confirm the quantity in Infinity, you can quantify the genetic toxic cargo that tends through the acs scalpel or the week miss
miss.  It is also possible to perform
ink profiling. In order to perform an accurate qualitative analysis on what kind of min pretty should be confirmed in ink profiling,
you can use the
high-resolution bath in u talk equipment to carry out the in pretty profiling
work.
Second,  Even in the case of metal cores, I know that the pharmacopoeia has been updated recently,
and the icp-ms loada analysis is in progress. You
can see that there are various solutions in this regard.
The work
of compiling and analyzing the head space of attention for
I think you can see that there is a business up, so you can see that there
are various analysis solutions for broken water fountains for kids
.  I will tell you what kind of equipment should be used to analyze the raw material or finished drug for the non-ssam pretty analysis
.  It
is possible to qualitatively confirm the material based on the screen or mdma, etc. This
week, it
is cheap because it is possible to confirm even qualitative analysis through the lc bath or through the lcb sms or lch ms int-top.
I introduced that toxic impurities can be analyzed for various inf dtd things related to
[Music]
I've told you so far about what solutions and equipment should be analyzed by
Aids.  Regarding the phosphorus analysis
, Agilent is developing the Si Constitution for various substances. About the results presented for
various analysis methods, such as Rosal Tanbul Uncovered tem 4 vs. 4 vs. 4
Next, we motivated the analysis method for 6 types of Adaito 3 Infinity from the Sartan nipple in the us ft US fda.
There are various analysis methods related to this.
It is based on ppb
. If you calculate and check the application of this to the sample in ppm units, you will get a 0.0 and
2pm level management regulation figure
.  In addition to the six types of
lct f code Lone Full Six 7 0  Using the ctf code application,
we analyzed the inpurities of more than 12 species in preparation for the 6 species. In fact, as you can see,
0 points per 0.1, which is a lower concentration than the 0.1 ppb level regulation figure erotic professor's house.  In this case, or 0.075 magpie
more Daz concentration, you can see that it is such a value that can do d characteristics at a lower concentration than the regulatory value,
so
you can confirm the main needle that can be detected at a lower concentration of 0.2 ppb water Lord above.
This is the current status of the actual analysis method.
As mentioned earlier, as a solution to a tent for
, you can see the results of analysis with equipment called Ultibo. In
fact, the total analysis method was analyzed in 25 minutes.
As you can see, and m a on  From b
nde to the final ndp
, the analysis method is divided more easily , and in fact , this analysis method is the analysis method for 5 -
year rounds . Since the concentration in the actual sample is about 1
20 mg per ml , if it enters itself due to the mass ,
the scalpel  It can be contaminated, so if
you look on the right, from 17 minutes or more, diver alter * fire is used
to maze.
As a result of the previous results, you can see the contents of the recovery rate among the raw materials for saltan. You can see that the recovery rate from the
rat received nmb n de lei p&i blood
is confirmed as the final plus - 20%. In
addition, up to m&b The recovery rate for a total of six is ​​showing appropriate results.
Then, the reproducibility results.
You can check the relative deviation for
a total of six species.  As you can see it is not easy to
an  Relative standard deviation percent rs for a total of 6 types from d ma to ni ba is
within 3%, and you can confirm very reproducible results
.  Common people can be caused by diet in various drugs.
Well, the same method is the result of three people analyzing Sartan as a light in a substance called Gavalin of Whye Pool.
This is
the result of analyzing the results. If
you look at the analysis method, the analysis was done within the final 15 minutes, and since the play is
too high concentration for the Bali 4 api raw material
, you can see that this is also the result of the paste being analyzed at 3 minutes.  Yes
, you can see good results at the 0.1 ppb level like the sluggish quantification limit.
This play has also progressed the recovery rate for balin.
Next, although the domestic Ministry of Food and Drug Safety previously announced the municipal constitution for 6 species, in addition to this
, various people from @i may
occur in Sartan
.  This is the result of the analysis of Knights 3 for a total of 6 species, and
as you
can see, this
can be confirmed with 100mg per ml, which is a little higher in sample size.  Since there is a potential for contamination, as a
result of checking with uv, you can confirm that you can be tagged for about 11 minutes.
In
relation to this, the recovery rate has also been carried out. The recovery rate is around 20% plus ms, a total of
six
The actual recovery rate for the middle shows suitable results.
Next, we developed the card company 5 included in the city constitution announced in Korea.
You can see the result of making West for more than 100 million 8 minutes by being picked at any time, and then choosing Taito 3
for 6 different types from the rest of the front stage
.  This is the result of confirming the recovery rate for stirrer. You can confirm that the recovery rate is confirmed
to be around 20% of the following 20% ​​plus taste at the level of 0.51 5 ppb in China.
We have developed an analysis method,
so
you can see the results of analyzing the purity of 12 items, including
a total of and mad
et len ​​mpe.  You can see the results that can be analyzed
. Based on the ua analysis method, among various api raw material sites or completely,
hey and man After the probability of occurrence of various types is confirmed,
it is possible to proceed with the analysis through the 2 o'clock constitution.
You can see the view sub method. Next, you
can check whether the company value is linear for the quantitative curve for the 12 hey.
As you can see, you can see the analysis results for the total three nine 0-point sphere weather
You can check the linearity of the total confirmation from bande ip and i p&p with n dma.
Next is the 4th bullet. For the balsatan, we are looking at the results of analyzing the nitro 3 people
.
When infinity is ahead  After that, it is t and after
that, it is
detected.  This is
the result of measuring the recovery rate at about epb level at a depth of 5 0.05 in relation to the
plus - you can see the lower recovery rate of a person in their 20s, so
you can confirm
the appropriate result.
You can see that it is the result of looking at the average value.
You can use various
light 3-person applications using
the sentence sms triple quadruple equipment.
You can see the results that can be analyzed up to 0.2 ppb.
So far, I have generally carried out with lcm sms triple quadruple equipment.
Well, I introduced the analysis method stacked with various lights.
Next, using a high resolution bath in acq top
I will tell you the results of the analysis. There is
a test method using 6546 agent lc two-top
.  The limit is 0.1 ppb,
0.0,
ppd 2, 0.25 bpb, and you can see the detection limit where you choose to a very low
level.
Yes, you can check the dialysis method using the cq top using the previous 6
death forces.
You can check the molecular weight for the
third decimal place, which is accurate from the node and ma to ndp you see.
15 You can confirm that this value comes in at about 5% or less. This
is the content that you can check the related information. I
will briefly introduce the equipment called agent cq turbo 946 by combining it with the actual analysis results.
In addition to the recognition Yang Woo-seok, infinity profiling is possible, so you can see it as a pass. The
reason for killing it is that it has a wide dynamic range next to my eyes.
I have the ability to collect this signal quickly.
Next time, the resolution that I think is most important in hr ms.
You can see it as such equipment that can be continuously analyzed without having to break the vacuum cut-off vacuum through the gate valve
. In relation to uh, through the q saw, through the hr mass, it is
possible to direct or infinity profiling to qualitative analysis  As you can
see, the lacey 5 of the element of copper is variously accurate,
and then the mass msf lamination
is used to generate the molecular formula for the related content through the information on the molecule and the polymer.
Finally, through the app cry, the actual foreign matter appears in some way and when it is rescued.
It is possible to analyze various applications in various markets, but the last
thing to pay attention to is the related application to the extractable penalty. Since it is not known what parts of Infiniti will emerge in the future in the pharmaceutical market, the approximate
library is matched to Infinity.
For the related content, it seems that it contains about 1000 or more compounds
.
Yes, I have briefly explained the contents of 654 rock so far
.  When I did
the
analysis, the results of analysis through hms high-resolution math or t f code application
math are shown.
As
you can see, you can check the analysis method for ranidine in the US FDA. As you can
see, there is a reason that n dma can occur for nanidin drug substance and finished drug.
As you can see, it is stipulated that if the concentration of 1 ppb water column sample is applied for one quantity
, it should be managed at a depth of 0.03 3 and level.
You can check the result of analyzing the n dma for the Rani quiz through the people who work and kill by using the rule toggle of the lc day given message.
As you can see, in the case of td a lot,
the erotic queue is 0.25  You can see that it is at the ppb level.
So, the quantitative
line for 0.25 PP to 100 bp is drawn. The r square value is 0.9, and q can be confirmed at the 0.25 ppv level against the line used by 2 stations.
analysis method
So, additionally, as
a result of analysis compared to and ma opp, the result of nd m&a in the following sample
Finally, api is a large amount of 20mg pie melo, so it is wasted because it is high temperature,
so that no idine enters the purchase for more than 8 minutes  You can see the goran method. As you
can see, you can
also see the agrush recovery rate.
A lot of auxiliary Very good 1 plus -
0 point because the recovery rate is broken within 15% Reason 0.5 1 5 10 25
Accrash with higher accuracy up to 50 times  I did the analysis with , and I
also did a little bit of hair. Because the exact molecular weight is important in , it
is also important for the molecular weight. As you
can see, you can see the result of a better brush for the tack.
This is the result of the gorgeous real and raw stone.
Likewise, you can see the analysis results with very reproducible results and accurate masser crush.
For Rani td 4, for n dma, low
medium
1.23 6 ppb, 94
196 can break a very good recovery rate.
Similarly, stocking for samples is even at the level of 50 ppb
.  You can see the test results that are suitable for you. Next, you can see the results of
the analysis with the
acm sstp code application in the 2010 and October.
Likewise, if I apply this king of the 1 ppv sample earlier
, the analysis must be conducted at a very low concentration at the level of 0.03 3 ppm of the
erocue.
As you can see, if you look at factory 2 b,
you can see the results of analyzing each parameter through
a cilantro.
For more than a minute, West
is ordered to raise it. This is the result to ensure that the actual 9 concentration does not enter the number of copies
. Earlier, it was used with equipment called Hexa 202, but currently
this ball is discontinued and
has a better equipment called Hexa 702  You can see
the results of the analysis.
You can show more suitable results within %, and in
fact, you can see suitable results for the finished drug product, not the fish egg 2 din hydrochloric acid reverse tool for the sample.
First of all, on the screen on the left, you can see the results of fish resilience for a total of 8 times. The
percentage rst is about 0.16%, so you can see the very controlled results.
In raw materials, if you look at the recovery for 1 0 1.23 6, you can see the
recovery rate is suitable even at very low temperatures,
and it is the same even in complete pain.
Through the
act f code or a cheese beef cattle breeding q tom, it is possible
not only to quantify fish purity, but also to qualitatively analyze and confirm the structural
level
of mpt.  Since the law is open to the
public, if you need it at any time, if you contact me,
you can electronically and disclose the related method, so
if you have any necessary information, please feel free to contact IZENT at any time
.
Today, regarding related matters, I reduce
the regulation update situation for genotoxic impurities in the market and
the act f code
1ch ms in high that can be analyzed in various ways
.
I told you about the workflow and experiment results that even proceed with the qualitative certification of fabricated 3 or phosphorus
4 4 Thank you for listening to me for 3 hours so far 4 So far, I
have not been presenting today.
There is
no situation for the entire market in relation to Fabricated Island, and
now you have time to look at the results of the analysis. If you have
any questions, please go to
the mng qna window below and register.  If you
do, I'll give the subject time to answer. I think
today's session is probably the last session 1. Please note
that all of today's sessions
are available for viewing
again.  Thank you for watching, if you
have any questions at that time, that's why. If you feel it in the qna window,
we will respond by e-mail.
Recently, the chief referee
conducted an analysis on his own, but an application that can be analyzed again in the general judgment outside the water room with the lcms scalpel method has
been developed
.
Since there are no people who have uploaded Que Nails right now
, please update the details of the park later,
and we will end the ol 3
ordeal here 4 Thank you for listening for a long time
.  There are spaces that have been placed.
Please pay a lot of attention. It would be nice if you fill out the sleeping system once and get a coffee snack.
Then, I will finish the session in the near future. Thank you.